Democrats humiliate themselves from
campaigning in Canada to filing fake
perjury charges against Brett Kavanaugh
and Serena Williams becomes the Hillary
Clinton of sports then stupid abortion
arguments self-hating Republicans and
big tech keeps turning the frickin frogs
gay I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
oh we have got so much to get to today
but before we do that I have got to
thank our new or so not that new sort of
relatively new sponsor purple mattress I
say this with such excitement because I
now have a purple mattress and it is
fantastic
it is so good it's really saving my
marriage to California King you can't
beat that it is so so good I'm a tricky
sleeper you know I can always sleep in
basically any situation but I don't get
very good quality sleep I spend the
night tossing and turning my neck is all
cooked it doesn't feel good until purple
mattress sleep is very important you
know me I need at least 18 or 19 hours
of sleep per day
purple mattress is the way to help you
get a good night's sleep I uses this
brand new material it was developed by
an actual rocket scientist and you know
I have simple tastes I'm easily
satisfied by the best
I need my bed created by a rocket
scientist this is so good it's both firm
and soft at the same time sleeps very
cool gives you the zero-gravity like
feel you're going to love it right now
my listeners get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress don't
say I never did nothing for you that's
in addition to the great free gifts they
get site-wide go-to purple calm promo
code cough FA Co V Fe Fe to check out
then you will get your free pillow and
you're gonna love this mattress the only
way to get the pillow is to use the
promo code cough FA Co V Fe Fe at purple
dot-com code kofi Fae okay
a banner weekend for leftist ears my
tumblr has been running over if this was
really bad from sea to shining sea from
the United States all the way up to
Canada for some reason from the halls of
Congress to the Supreme Court a
wonderful weekend for a leftist ears and
one thing that it showed by the way is
that the left and the Democrats as the
vessel of the left are really bad sports
they're really you know in politics
sometimes you win sometimes you lose and
when you lose you know you lick your
wounds you regroup and then you fight
next time what you don't do is sit there
and whine and cry and wham wham wham
that is all we have been getting from
the left
it is totally unserious at the US Open
Serena Williams became the avatar of the
left to these days
see all of the conservatives who watched
that saw her and they said oh my gosh
Serena Williams is Hillary Clinton Roger
Kimball wrote a good piece on it we'll
get to all of that but we've got to
start with David Hogg he's that young
teenage gun grabber enthusiast because
the question with the Democrats is are
they genuinely ignorant or are they
being obtuse or are they just pretending
are they just playing some cynical game
so let's give them the benefit of the
doubt let's start on the generous end of
the spectrum the completely ignorant
side of things for that we have to go up
to the Toronto Film Festival with
Michael Moore and David Hawk I'd like to
give the microphone to them just fake it
if we have time we'll we'll take a
couple questions but I'd like to start
with David Hogg here to say a few words
they thank you so here Michael Moore
made one of the classic blunders he
thought that David Hogg would just say a
few words and David Hogg has never just
said a few words in his life as we're
about to find out but it almost sounds
like the beginning of a joke you know
David Hogg and Michael Moore go to the
Toronto Film Festival this is a hotbed
of leftism it is an avatar it is a
symbol of what the left is doing in
American politics here are some of the
young benighted mr. Hogg's arguments I
have a question for you guys who's ready
to save America who's ready to make
America the country that we say is on
paper and make it the actual country
that it wants to be
[Applause]
I think it's the the most important
thing to realize however it's the
problems that we face as a country
whether it be water in Flint Michigan or
the amount of mass incarceration of
people in Cuyler of color that can't
vote in Florida the amount of eligible
African Americans that would otherwise
be eligible to vote that can't because
of a previous conviction is 21% in
Kentucky it's 26% in Mississippi and
Alabama it's 15 to 16 percent these are
people of color that have been
historically discriminated against and
still are to this day and have their
voting rights taken away it's exactly
turn that shame into your vote turn that
shame into your vote except we're in
Canada so here we have now David hogging
the Democrats promoting election fraud
Canadians go vote either really they
really are trying to steal elections now
probably what it is is he just forgot he
was in Canada he doesn't know that much
about politics the reason I point out
this little segment though is I want to
point out the racism of this argument we
hear this a lot from Democrats they say
you know we lock up all of our criminals
we lock up so many criminals and by the
way that's why the crime rate has
decreased so markedly over the last few
decades but we lock up our criminals and
that is racist somehow and the premise
of that argument is that criminals and
black people are the same thing but
they're not the same thing that's a bit
that's a very offensive thing to say the
Democrats keep saying that locking up
criminals is not racist that's just a
matter of justice black people are not
criminals those are not synonymous and
when they make that argument it really
you just think you know that they are
always arguing about white privilege
you're think that is the most blind
tone-deaf privileged argument I've ever
heard but then he gets to correct the
record on Canadians voting I can AI
think Canadians can donate to political
campaigns in the United States they
can't well well
vote here makes because
[Applause]
this poor kid is is saying all of this
nonsense he's spouting all of his
ignorance and then he's turning to
Michael Moore and he says do they can
they can they donate to political no
they can when you have to turn to
Michael Moore to get your knowledge
about the American political system you
are in deep trouble that is not a good
place to be in cities as well vote here
and this is something that the left does
all the time
III noticed this whenever you argue
about one particular issue with the left
you'll help say their crazy point then
you'll say your point and you'll shut
down their idea and then they'll just
change the topic and they'll say well
what about this you see with abortion
you say abortion is bad and we shouldn't
have any abortion and it shouldn't be
legal and they say yeah but how much
welfare spending should we spend on kids
you say well that's a separate topic I'm
not talking about that you say you're
talking about some war or something in
the Iraq war and they say yeah well how
much money should we spend on public
schools so I'm not talking about public
schools I'm trying I'm talking about the
Iraq they keep moving it because they
have to move the goal posts they don't
have any argument on the topic that
you're actually at talking about and
then there is just the blithe ignorance
and this was the PS teller resistance I
took the lid off of my tumblr so that I
could fill it up from Toronto take it
away mr. Hogg I this question if to the
IRS if you're watching on Facebook why
aren't you auditing the President of the
United States who likely got thirty
million dollars from Russia via the NRA
there's an active Department of Justice
investigation into this that nobody's
talking about also we're still at war in
Afghanistan what the hell like I'm I'm
18 years old that war was started 17
years ago think about that also Cheez
doodles are orange also it's kind of
chilly outside now because it's the fall
also you're just saying random facts
also pepperoni pizza is delicious
it's just sputtering and sputtering
right yes of course we can discuss the
war in Afghanistan i I don't know that
think about that is really the best way
to do it but this point he mentions
which is that the NRA spent 30 million
dollars that it got from Russia on the
Trump campaign that is simply not true
that is just flat-out false he says that
nobody's talking about that
we know how much money the NRA got from
the Russians whoo boris and Natasha whoo
the NRA received about $2,500 from the
Russians that is slightly less slightly
more rather than an order of magnitude
off from what David August said two
orders of magnitude off from what David
Hogg said and the NRA has owned up to
this they've said yeah we've gotten some
money from a lot of different places and
we can trace some Russian nationals they
gave us about $2,500 now you might ask
why was that number so low mostly
because it's membership fees you know
this if you join the NRA you pay 30
bucks a year 100 bucks a year and then
you get your little membership card into
the NRA so that's what he's talking
about there's a big difference between
that and thirty million dollars more
importantly nonprofits can take money
from whomever they like it's not like a
political campaign they can take money
from any sources they like how do we
know this because the Clinton Foundation
did this for years and years in a way
that the left had told us that's
perfectly fine do you remember Saudi
Arabia gave the Clinton Foundation 25
million dollars which is close to the
number that David hogs talking about
maybe that's where he got the idea from
so they give the Clinton Foundation 25
million dollars and then Hillary Clinton
is Secretary of State approves a twenty
nine billion dollar arms sale to Saudi
Arabia that there might be some problems
with that we might want to look into
that but it's perfectly fine for the NRA
to get membership dues from people
around the world especially when those
membership dues don't add up to very
much this just shows the left is really
not to be taken seriously here we've
really entered into silly season they're
getting basic facts wrong they don't
care that they're getting basic facts
wrong and I don't even want to just beat
up on David hog because the elected
Democrats and Democratic operatives are
no better they're no more serious it's
the the Democrat Party has decayed into
a dying vaudeville show nowhere has that
become clearer then at the Brett
Kavanaugh confirmation hearings there
was a big press release that came out
over the weekend Democratic coalition so
this is a super PAC that helps Democrats
and left-wing candidates the Democratic
coalition sends out this press release
it says quote Democratic coalition files
criminal complaint against judge Brett
Kavanaugh
for perjury in congressional testimony
okay what's what are they talking about
what they're talking about is that a
decade or so ago it's during some
congressional testimony they think that
Break haveno lied
even though actual legal experts don't
think he lied at all and there's no
evidence that he lied so that's what
they're saying they're talking about
perjury and a congressional testimony a
decade ago which didn't happen then the
press release goes on it says a separate
judicial ethics complaint will be
submitted on Monday to the clerk of the
DC Circuit for Chief Judge Merrick
garland to review oh how delicious
Merrick garland passed over for the
Supreme Court Barack Obama sort of
nominated him Republicans wouldn't let
him sit oh wow is this gonna be good the
only problem with this tactic is that
it's not even true
it won't work and it's not even true
we'll get to that in a second but first
I have to thank wonderful sponsor
Express VPN you know if you're watching
this show I know that you look at some
weird stuff on the Internet okay I know
that you need to protect your privacy on
the Internet
if you I'm obvious I'm talking about
daily wire comm you need to get
expressvpn I'm serious you should not be
on the internet open and exposed you
need a VPN to just cover up all these
security breaches we've been seeing all
of the Facebook and Twitter and all the
social media people going in front of
Congress saying that they are not taking
privacy seriously when you make an
online purchase or even simply access
your email you could be putting your
private information at risk you're being
tracked by social media by marketing
companies all over the other day I was
just talking about a type of shoe in the
green room and then I started getting
ads for the shoe that is really creepy
noses on my phone thank goodness I use
expressvpn
on my computer it secures and anonymizes
your internet browsing it encrypts your
data it's just seven bucks a month do it
do it today this is the best seven bucks
you will spend go do it expressvpn comm
slash michael mi CH AE l you will get
three months free expressvpn expr ESS
VPN comm slash michael mi CH AE l three
months free with one-year package
expressvpn comm slash Michael that is
the problem with this demo
strategy the only problem with it is
that it's not true they say they're
filing a criminal complaint against
Brett Kavanaugh the way we know this
isn't true is that it isn't possible
private citizens cannot file criminal
complaints with the federal court system
that's not how it works you can so what
they did do is they wrote a letter to
the Department of Justice and they said
we really want you to punish Brett
Kavanaugh so what actually what the
press release should have said is press
release breaking Democratic coalition
writes a strongly worded letter a
strongly worded letter to the other
aspects by the way is Merrick garland is
an appeals court judge so if they have
some ethical complaint about judge
Kavanaugh they're not it's not going to
go to Merrick garland it's not going to
go to a district judge period it's not
going to go to an appeals judge it's
gonna go to the entity that holds Bret
Cavanaugh's law license even voxcom
admits that this is nonsense
and you know for voxcom to say it I
don't defer to Viacom and a lot of
issues but even the left here is saying
this is all show but these are the big
headlines over the weekend this is the
big viral news story why are they doing
this why are they running on craziness
up in Toronto and these fake press
releases that are just a pure lie in the
headline it's because they have nothing
else to run on what are they going to
run on they box themselves in we've been
hearing about Russia gate for two years
this is this investigation the Muller
investigation was going on for over two
years and what have we gotten out of it
we found out that Paul Manafort likes
expensive suits and just in the last few
days they've sentenced george
papadapolis he's the trump staffer who
spoke to a maltese professor who had
ties to the Russian government who
probably is best friends with Vladimir
Putin I don't I made that last part up
and what did the sentence deliver what
have we got for George papadopolis 14
days in prison two weeks in prison
14 days 200 hours community service 13
months super supervised release a nine
thousand dollar fine and 14 days in
prison
this really beggars belief this really
beggars belief I think the Democrats put
all of their eggs in this basket they
were so shocked and upset by the 2016
election they
said this can't happen we just have to
undo it if they'd spent that time
creating a positive agenda they might
have something to run on right now but
they don't so they're just retreating
back and back they say it didn't happen
it didn't really happen please no
Trump's really a Manchurian Candidate
nobody is believing them and so this
question or the Democrats being obtuse
or the Democrats being ignorant here I
think at this point this far in it is
very hard to conclude that they're not
just being obtuse they're not playing a
cynical vaudeville game and I've got
some more evidence of this in what is
undoubtedly the most ridiculous video on
the Internet I this was going all around
Twitter if this is from Liz plank at
elle.com because in the Cavanaugh
hearings abortion has been the big topic
even when they're not openly talking
about it everything is about roe v wade
or you gonna overturn roe women's health
that's the euphemism they use women's
reproductive health that's the crazy
euphemism they use because abortion and
reproduction are diametrically opposed
to one another
so here is what passes for comedy and
argumentation on the Left l.com making a
video about abortion introducing male
masturbation crisis centers sometimes
self-love happens and just because you
do it alone doesn't mean that you are
alone no seriously how did you get in
here look Trevor when you're going five
against one you're not just rubbing one
out
in fact you're rubbing out 70 to 300
million sperm the actual seeds of life
what men must respect these potential
lives and that's where we come in as it
is currently law in 35 states in the
case of abortion we offer mandate a
preliminary consultation up to 48 hours
before your masturbation event after all
we want you to be fully aware of all of
your options and consequences when you
choose to tickle your pickle look if
you're under the age of 18 and are
thinking about masturbation we'll ask
your parents before you can follow Emily
Ratajkowski Instagram to see where she
travels do you get it do you get the
point that she's the sort of point she's
trying to make you get it what she's
saying is that men masturbation is just
like getting an abortion now I can't
believe that I even have to explain this
but I think I do because the left has
failed biology 101 they failed health
class
they were probably all outside you know
who knows what they were smoking behind
the gymnasium that's probably why the
legalization campaign is so big on the
left right now a sperm cell is not the
same thing as an unborn baby it's not
the same thing genetically it's not the
same thing biologically if you leave
them uninterrupted one of them will just
remain a cell the other one will become
a full-grown human person who can make
stupid videos like that one and I wonder
if this is because they don't get the
argument or they just refuse to engage
with it they never engage with the
argument at these Cavanagh hearings
Kamala Harris Cory Booker they never
engage with real arguments it was all
shows and distractions to the other side
and let's just drill down into what this
is if Brett Kavanaugh is confirmed which
he almost certainly will be people are
worried these hostile to roe v wade and
that he'll overturn roe v wade i'm not
so sure about that ab n is not so sure
about that Ben thinks that he would not
actually have returned roe v wade they
might play some further restrictions on
abortion but that there's enough
precedent that Cavanaugh in his judicial
opinion wouldn't overturn it who knows
we'll have to see what happens with the
left is saying is that if roe v wade
gets overturned then we're going to have
abortion outlawed across the country
that's not true
what happens if roe v wade is overturned
is that the question is returned to the
states and some states will have legal
abortion some states will not have legal
abortion that's our federal system
that's a wonderful thing what they're
the left is also saying is that the
Constitution has a right to abortion
enshrined in it and I have to ask them
I've never gotten a good answer to this
do they really believe that James
Madison and Alexander Hamilton sat down
said okay we're gonna have a free speech
in there yeah we're gonna have a balance
of power separation of powers and oh hey
Alexander don't forget the right to an
abortion you can't forget the right to
an abortion in there that's that's what
we fought that revolution for isn't it
Alexander of course not nobody thinks
that that is the case but the left is
not playing politics in good faith here
they're not playing but they're
interrupting the hearings they're making
a total show of the hearing
they're pretending that all of you know
millions and millions of documents need
to be read from when Brett Kavanaugh was
in middle school or else we can't decide
if he's an able judge the man's been a
judge for a long time people on both
sides of the aisle say he's a very
competent judge they're not playing
politics in good faith they know that
they lost they're still really sore
about lose in that election and rather
than regrouping or using legal or
serious means of trying to counter the
current president they're throwing these
hysterics they're just throwing a total
temper tantrum and this is why total
providence all nature is but art unknown
to thee over the weekend to the US Open
we got to see as Serena Williams embody
the Democrat Party I wish I wish he had
actually played her game at the at the
Congress but Serena Williams if you
didn't watch it the US Open a Naomi
Osaka won she was not expected to win
Serena Williams was expected to win and
Serena Williams lost why does Serena
Williams lose because she got outplayed
by Naomi Osaka that's how that says
sports work every conservative every
Republican who was watching this game
was watching Serena Williams have this
meltdown and just thinking huh this
looks a lot like national politics so
for the last two years huh if someone
got outplayed and then rather than being
a good sport about it they'd break down
and start crying Roger Kimball wrote up
this great piece on it where he kept
referring to
Serena Clinton and Hillary Williams so
here is the the way this first started
is that Serena Williams got called for
cheating not big cheating not the crazy
cheating but she got she was getting a
sign from her coach and she got called
out on it she didn't think she was going
to get caught and she loses it here's
Serena Williams Carlos Ramos to the
chair
you don't know that and understand why
you may have thought out but that was
coaching
not I don't cheat you in the coaching
violation Megan's a thumbs up and
Serena's setting him straight that is
not
so not a good way to start if she gets
called on this she immediately goes up
deny deny deny and but by the way her
coach later Patrick Mouratoglou admitted
that he was giving the signal he did
admit later so now she looks like she's
got a lot of egg on her face and there
were two aspects here one Serena
Williams's first instinct is deny it get
up in that guy's face say no what dare
you call me on that that wasn't what it
was I'm letting you know that but then
you heard the commentator there the
commentator said Oh Serena Williams is
just setting him straight so well I
don't know if she's setting him straight
did she get the sign or not she did get
the sign we all saw it there are cameras
all over the place did she get the sign
or not to Hillary Clinton wipe the
server or not did Hillary Clinton get
the money from Saudi Arabia or not we
all saw it
stop telling us not to believe our lying
eyes but then it gets even worse from
there because it starts out now Serena's
getting really agitated really upset and
then she finally loses her temper
publicly
[Applause]
sir
[Applause]
smash that one
carrot violation record abuse
to mrs. rutter's code violation private
email server code violation what do you
mean private so Serena Williams just
takes her her racket just smashes it on
the ground which you're not supposed to
do for a couple reasons one it's a
violation and - it's not how a sportsman
plays it's unsportsmanlike u @ you don't
have any sportsmanship when you're doing
that because it's not just all about
Serena Williams she doesn't just get to
win the game just cuz just because she
is who she is Hillary Clinton doesn't
get to become president just cuz Jessica
the waltz her turn it's her she's waited
long enough it's her turn that's all
about Hillary there's no one else is
even running are they it's just Hillary
and all of the distractions and it's
that same thing you know Hillary
Clinton's private email server was
discovered what did she do she just
hurled a bunch of bleach bit on top of
it she just wiped the whole thing up
whoops sorry did you senator Clinton
Secretary Clinton did you wipe your
server what did I wipe it with a cloth
just very very angry and then finally
worst of all she just loses her cool at
the umpire
I didn't get coaching you need to take
you need to make an announcement that I
didn't get coaching I don't cheat I
didn't get coaching how can you say that
[Applause]
you are after cheating in my life I have
a daughter in established right
everything
[Applause]
apology
spoiler alert she's not gonna get her
apology but as your you owe me an
apology
my opponents are deplorable and
irredeemable you owe me you say you're
sore it was the Macedonians it was the
clique forms with the Russians there was
okay Hillary yeah that's fine
really looks awful totally losing her
cool screaming she's sort of on the
verge of tears and then what you heard
in there you heard about 3/4 of the way
through it's the beginning of the
identity politics here that she said I
have a daughter and I haven't cheated so
what what does that have to do with
anything we say I didn't cheat and then
the the umpire can point out no you did
I saw it and we all saw it
you're your coach admitted it you did
you know I didn't and I have a daughter
okay I had a tuna sandwich for lunch
great okay if we're talking about things
that don't matter whatsoever she loses
her cool and he stands firm now this is
a pretty strict umpire Carlos Ramos
apparently he's a little more rigid than
other umpires but he's sticking to his
guns fair enough and then when she's not
getting what she wants when he's not
gonna kowtow to her and said well you're
crying okay you can have it she loses it
and she goes full identity politics
Serena was watching her coach give her
hands emotion
[Music]
you can't Xavier thief because you stole
away from me but I'm not a cheater
[Music]
for all the parents out there what would
you do if your child behaved this way
because listen now that argument goes
she cuz you know you're a thief
you're deplorable and irredeemable
that's what that's what Sarina Clinton
would have said she's like you're a
thief and he's okay that's a violation
that's verbal abuse you're not allowed
to verbally abuse the umpire but I did
it cuz you stole a point from me but no
I didn't you cheated and I saw it and
then I took a point for you well within
the rules well but you but you should
apologize no I'm not apologizing for
anything do timeout you go to time it's
true by they don't have timeout that's
what they should have done that's what
they should have done to Serena and and
then we get we get the final straw this
is the this is the Hillary Clinton what
happened book this is the post-election
what happened book of the US Open take
it away
Serena Clinton
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is not fair I'm good I'm gonna lose
a game just cuz I lost a game I'm what
you're good telling me that just cuz I
lost that game I'm gonna lose oh and and
I I lost a point cuz I cheated and
you're saying that's not fair to lose a
point if you're cheap that's not fair I
was supposed to win Wisconsin I was
supposed to win Pennsylvania that's not
fair that's not fair and so then you
know that that's not a great argument
you know I I lost and therefore I lost
that's not fair so then she moves on she
said so you're gonna take this away from
me because I'm a woman I know we're
gonna take it away from you because you
lost we're actually not taking anything
away from you it wasn't yours to begin
with
you lost it's actually Naomi Osaka's
that's who as it is cuz she won and you
lost you're taking it away cuz I'm a
woman no they actually the winner is a
woman - spoiler alert eight - break it
to you you can't it you know if only if
she had been playing a mate well if she
had been playing a man you know it would
have been over a lot longer a lot sooner
than that but that's not it's not fair
it's not fair it's not fair this is
being a really bad sport and and it's
too bad too because this girl Naomi
Osaka did win you know Donald Trump did
win somebody did win the election but it
just becomes all about the loser when
you're a really bad sport and this is
why this is why disrespecting the flag
is so bad this is why the all of that
not my president stuff is so bad we'll
explain why in a sec but I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube I'm
sorry I can't believe we're still on
Facebook and YouTube frankly I figured
we'd have gotten censored a long time
ago we're gonna talk about social media
censorship at the very end and how you
know they're permitting all of the
freaking frogs to turn gay but before we
do that I have got to tell you if you're
on Daily wire calm it look it's ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me at the end or
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you have to ask questions in the mail
bag mail bags coming up on Thursday
don't forget that you'll get to ask
questions in the conversation next one
up with the big boss himself ben shapiro
but none of that matters this is what
matters the leftist tears tumblr you get
this is a frothy brew i actually don't
know if it's
even legal if it's non-toxic to mix up
the David Hogg Democratic coalition and
Serena Williams brew is this is that
okay is that as any has that even been
done before the only way that you can
even try it I recommend is in the
leftist tiers tumbler any other vessel
will just dissolve in your hand it'll
probably put burn marks on your hand
don't do that don't let yourself be
caught unawares go to daily wire calm
get the leftist tears tumblr we'll be
right back
this is why all of this burn you know
not burning the flag but kneeling in
front of the flag disrespecting the flag
Nike putting Colin Kaepernick on it's on
it's ads all of the not my president
stuff this is why it's so offensive is
it so unsportsmanlike it this isn't how
we're supposed to behave in a country
when you look people lose elections the
the politics swings back and forth and
bagging where sometimes you're gonna
lose lick your wounds regroup go back
and I will say I don't think there's a
moral equivalence here between the left
and the right I think when the right
lost the right regrouped there was a
great movement called the Tea Party
movement which was not about whining and
screaming and making up things and
saying it's not fair that I lost it was
about going back to constitutional
arguments going back I mean it was a one
of the greatest civics lessons in
American history was the tea party they
said no we need to get back to this we
need to rein in this aspect of
government we need to rein in the
regulatory stay we needed up up up up up
they had an agenda and they
systematically kept electing people from
the local all the way up to the federal
level so they were able to do that in
the Tea Party what is the left doing
they're just whining and screaming
trying to undo the election I really
don't think there's moral equivalence
and if you don't respect the flag then
you're not respecting the if you're if
you're disrespecting both the game you
know actually having the national anthem
in the sports game and the flag
generally as a symbol of the country
you're not playing along with the team
you're going against the core aspect of
American identity and that is really
ugly
nobody wants a country like that you
know we've got to live with each other
we've got to live with these people so
you've got you've got to kind of get
along and at the end of the game even if
you lose and the other guy wins instead
of throwing your racket on the ground
you've got to go around and say okay
good game I'll get you next time but
good game and it's this aspect of
partisanship that had me a little
disappointed in senator Ben Sasse over
the weekend here is senator Seth saying
he might leave the GOP home state
senator thanks so much for joining us I
have to start yesterday you retweeted
someone who said that they switched
their party registration from Democrats
and no party and you replied by saying
you quote regularly consider
switch switching from the Republican
Party to becoming an independent as well
why and what's stopping you from doing
so yeah so I'm one of about eight people
in the US Senate who's never been a
politician before and I think I've been
saying for three years that I conceive
of myself as an independent conservative
who caucuses with the Republicans but
frankly neither of these parties have a
long-term vision for the future of the
country you know ten years from now
where are we gonna be in the future of
work when young people are disrupted out
of jobs three times a decade future war
and cyber that collapse a community like
there's massive stuff happening in
America and these parties are really
pretty content to do 24-hour news cycles
screaming at each other
the main thing that the Democrats are
for is being anti Republican an
anti-trump but the main thing
Republicans are for is being anti
Democrat and anti CNN and here we go it
seems to me I have heard this song
before you hear this I also love the
idea that Senator sass is complaining
about politicians going on the 24-hour
news cycle while he is on CNN while he
is on the 24-hour news cycle
I like senator sass I think he's super
smart I think he could be a great help
to the conservative movement into the
GOP and to the country broadly but he's
playing this game right now I call it
being a Republican but not that kind of
Republican it's really you got to say it
really faster to youth you see this a
lot with Republicans who want to be
liked by CNN in the New York Times you
seen a lot of college kids are like this
they say oh I'm a Republican but I'm not
that kind of Republican don't wait no
I'm not a bad guy you know I hope he
cuts this out because first of all the
New York Times is never going to like
you CNN is never going to like you
they're gonna use you while you're
valuable to them well you're a good
cudgel against other Republicans and
then they're gonna totally dismiss you
when you pose a threat to Democrats but
also you need a team
you do need a team I'm not saying we
need super uber partisanship I'm just
pointing out the reality of politics
which is that it is a team sport and
look at the left right now is the left
getting less partisan do you think the
Democrats are getting a less partisan
all of a sudden that's not what I see in
the wacky vaudeville show that's going
on in the congressional hearings right
now that's not what I'm seeing all
across the country in fundraising I'm
seeing them doubling down there there
our candidates for the Democrats running
on impeachment there's supposed to be a
legal basis for impeachment
they're throwing that out the window
they're saying it's pure partisanship
it's pure politics you need a team and
that this is not the time to start
sniping against your own guys I think
people need to regroup because they're
they're coming after us in a united
front both in the civil society and in
the government and nowhere is that more
clear than in social media so you see
this right now on the social media
platforms a uniformly they are attacking
people who issued left-wing orthodoxy
and I'm choosing my words carefully here
I'm not saying that they're just
targeting conservatives where they're
just targeting liberal Republicans or
they're just targeting fiscal
conservatives as socially Laura I'm not
saying or they're just are getting wacko
people who are at on the fringes that
isn't true what they're doing is they're
coming for every single person who is
shoes leftist orthodoxy I'm making it to
draw that distinction home I will point
out that Apple has finally kicked Alex
Jones off of its app so you know Alex
Jones he's the conspiracy theorist he's
the shirtless vitamin salesman but he
was kicked off of Twitter why they
initially they said he could stay on
Twitter and they said he couldn't stay
on Twitter they kicked him off of all of
his social media platforms they kicked
him off his podcast but the app was
allowed to remain they never said that
he violated a rule or anything they just
kicked it off which means that now now
that he's off of all of social media
he's off of his app we will not be able
to get important political commentary
like this I don't like a button
chemicals in the water it's they turn
the friggin frogs gay yeah me neither me
neither Alex but I point that out
because look is this the conservative
agenda to change the water so that the
frickin frogs stop turning gay I don't
think that's the conservative agenda but
they're going after him too why why is
the left going after him why is big tech
going after Alex Jones because he's the
easiest one to get he's the look who's
gonna argue against taking that guy off
of the air no no none of the
self-respecting conservatives who read a
lot of books and wear tweed jackets and
things like that but he's just the entry
point because they're gonna go after him
then they're gonna go after
Gavan McGinnis off of a bunch of social
media platforms now Gavin he Kevin's
been on Fox News Gavin's been a much
more mainstream figure he found advice
media then so then they're gonna and who
are they gonna go after next who are
they gonna go after next it's all of
this line eventually over the weekend we
saw Twitter kick-off not crazy Alex
Jones not a comedian like Gavin McGinnis
not they kicked off kris paronto who is
a CIA security contractor at the
Benghazi compound he was there fighting
during the attack on our compound and
our consulate in Benghazi why did they
kick him off because he criticized and
corrected the record when Barack Obama
lied about Benghazi and they kicked him
off of Twitter for that this is this is
what he said he said quote well Barack
Obama previously had said that
Republicans and conservatives have
delved into conspiracy theories about
Benghazi what's the conspiracy theory so
he responded kris paronto said benghazi
is a conspiracy barack obama how about
we do this let's put your cowardly
behind on the top of a roof with six of
your buddies and shoot RPGs and ak-47s
at you while terrorists lob 81
millimeter mortars killing two of your
buddies all well waiting for US support
that you never sent hashtag scum
so is it first of all how did they kick
him off they probably were saying oh he
threatened Barack Obama that's not a
threat he is he is relating his
experience at the Benghazi compound when
help didn't come because the Obama
administration did not respond
appropriately to the Benghazi attack and
then worse yet afterward they covered it
up if anybody's going to talk about a
conspiracy the conspiracy was from the
Obama administration when they lied
about it they said it wasn't a terrorist
attack they blamed it on some ridiculous
YouTube video and he corrects the record
and he gets suspended for them he gets
suspended this is what's happening this
is a preview because the left broadly
blames social media platforms for the
2016 election that before social media
before all of the new media the left
controlled the mainstream media
narrative the the American voters
couldn't get conservative perspectives
if they weren't distorted and perverted
by the left-wing lens of the mainstream
media with the new media that came out
with the internet with social media
conservatives could get their point of
view across unvarnished they could
control their own message in their own
political destiny and they have never
forgiven them for that they're raking
them over the coals social media is
responding to it and it's only gonna get
worse this is all about the midterms
they're gonna and if it works in the
midterms they're gonna amp it up for
2020 this is not the time for that I'm a
Republican but not that kind of
Republican attitude for sucking up to
the New York Times or CNN we really
should stop it if the Democrats win the
midterms we get impeachment if the
Democrats win the Senate we might get a
conviction there's still a lot of things
that we need to accomplish and it's time
that we get serious about accomplishing
it before the midterms okay now we've
got to move on to things I hate and
things I like why are we doing man well
it's because for today and tomorrow I'm
sitting in for Ben's radio show you know
Ben has a radio show that goes at all
across the country
so I'm sitting in for that I want to
really channel Ben you know I did
sriracha Sean a happy Rosh Hashanah to
all of my Jewish friends and so I really
want to channel him and I don't have the
yarmulke
although Prager you did give me one a
few years ago which I refer to as my
prettier you mocha but I don't have that
I'm not gonna really be able to do that
I don't I don't know enough about the
history of Rosh Hashanah it's the way
I'm gonna channel is I'm gonna do things
I hate and things I like I'll do it real
quick things I hate waking up early to
do Ben's radio show I really you know
you know me I need to get at least 17 to
19 hours of sleep per night for Ben's
radio show you got to wake up pretty
early but that's okay because things I
like is doing a Ben's radio show I don't
even do we even tell Ben that I'm doing
this I basically just kicked down the
door and busted in and I said we're
doing the radio show so so I need you to
do is go over and just send the link to
the radio I think we're on WABC send the
links to the radio show just all over
the place and get those numbers really
high and I want Ben to just have his jaw
on the floor steam coming out of his
ears when he comes back from celebrating
the holiday that's my request thank you
I'll be back tomorrow to and make sure
you get your mail back questions in for
Thursday because there is a lot of stuff
to cover this week in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show I will see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018